[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes le 21 avril 2015 il
est l'heure de faire le tour de
l'actualité yvelinoise voici les titres
de ce journal Le Sami Social de Paris
intervient à trappe et propose
actuellement au Mall logé un accueil
sanitaire et social plus de 15000 jeunes
inscrits dans le réseau de l'école de la
deuxème chance à travers la France 11
ans après sa création le dispositif qui
vient en aide aux jeunes décrocheur
scolaires à trouver toute sa place sur
le marché du travail bilan sur le site
de trappe avec sa directrice en plateau
invité de cette édition et puis jurassi
parc à toiri les dinosaures traversent
l'Atlantique pour s'installer au milieu
des girafes ours et autres tigres à
partir du 30 mai et jusqu'à la fin de
l'été le parc de toiri innove et propose
de nouvelles
scénographie le Samu Social de Paris est
donc actuellement à trappe il se déplace
même en bus le but proposer un accueil
sanitaire et social au mal logés à
proximité de l'accueil de l'hôtel pardon
qui les accueille Mathilde capernet et
le
dimoine originaire de la Côte d'Ivoire
aata vit en France depuis 2 ans comme
36000 personn en île-de-fance elle est
hébergée à l'hôtel en situation précaire
l'accès au droit et à la santé devient
difficile beaucoup de problèmes que on a
on a on a à ça ici en France ici c'est
ça on vient ici pour pour parler
d'accord problème de papier problème de
travail tout pour le pour la santé tout
ça le Samu Social de Paris propose un
accueil aux familles à bord d'un bus
l'avantage de cette démarche la
proximité ils y établissent un
diagnostic sanitaire et social sans
rendez-vous on s'est rendu compte que
les familles étaient très isolées parce
que souvent elles sont hébergées en en
grande banlieu et enfin en grande
couronne et et c'est assez difficile
parce que elles ont leur démarche par
exemple sur Paris donc à chaque démarche
il faut qu'elle se déplace sur Paris et
le fait de pouvoir leur proposer des des
services qui sont à proximité de leur
hôtel déjà ça leur permet de de faire un
point de savoir un peu ce qu'elles
peuvent entreprendre que ça soit au
niveau du sanitaire ou du social le bus
est composé d'une équipe de C tous
salariés à pleintemps les familles sont
accueillies par un chauffeur celui-ci
prend les premières informations avant
de les rediriger vers l'assistante
sociale l'infirmière ou le médecin on
part de la demande de la famille qui
nous explique ses difficultés et à
partir de là en fonction on voit avec
elle en fonction de elle ce qu'elle peut
faire de son autonomie euh de ses
repères quelle orientation peut proposer
pour répondre à sa difficulté sur le 78
il y a beaucoup de personnes qui sont
sans sécurité sociale donc ils peuvent
pas accéder aux soins parce qu'ils ont
pas de couverture maladie et là on se
rend compte que il y a de réelles
difficultés par rapport à ça en moyenne
5 à 10 familles sont reçues par jour
depuis un an le bus voyage en
Île-de-France il stationnera dans les
iveline jusqu'à la fin du mois de
mai l'invité de ce soir la responsable
de l'école de la deuxème chance attrappe
Monique premiski bonsoir bonsoir les
écoles de la deuxième chance ont été
fondées il y a un peu plus de 10 ans par
edit gresson afin de permettre
l'intégration professionnelle et sociale
des jeunes sortis du système éducatif
sans qualification et sans emploi et
justement le bilan pour cette dernière
année vient d'être rendu
14385 jeunes qui sont inscrits sur près
de 107 sites à travers la France c'est
une progression d' 1,7 % au niveau
national dans les ivelines
spécifiquement sur votre antenne de de
trappe est-ce que vous constatez la même
dynamique alors nous n'avons pas de
progression puisque notre école est
dimensionnée pour accueillir 100 jeunes
par an donc effectivement la demande est
régulière maintenant elle s'est inscrit
dans la régularité on a on a des jeunes
qui qui contactent l'école de la deuxiè
chance donc via les partenaires via le
boucheore et reconnu connu et reconnu
c'est le principe est-ce qu'il faut y
voir malgré tout un signe inquiétant
aussi ça veut dire que le système
scolaire classique ne répond pas de plus
en plus souvent aux besoins spécifiques
de de ces jeunes qui quittent l'école je
ne pense pas que ce soit un signe plus
inquiétant qu'il y a quelques années
mais
effectivement il faut s'interroger sur
voilà tous ces jeunes c'est une priorité
qui sort du système scolaire sans
diplôme sans qualification sans rien
alors le le le l'école de la deuxème
chance c'est véritablement une réponse
pour ces jeunes et il faut je pense
qu'il faut vraiment se mettre dans la
peau de ces jeunes ou se dire que le
système éducatif n'est pas fait pour
tout le monde n'est pas adapté à chaque
jeune et que il arrive à un moment donné
où ses parcours s'arrêtent et voilà par
des motivations par différentes raisons
et ces jeunesah trouent effectivement
quelque chose à l'école de la deuxième
chance quel est le profil de ces jeunes
justement l'orage alors le profil de ces
jeunes c'est des jeunes qui ont entre 18
et moins de 26 ans les jeunes ont une
moyenne d'âge âge de 20 ans 20 ans quand
ils arrivent à l'école alors on a une
formidable parité sur sur l'école on a à
quelques pourcentage près on est sur 50
% d'hommes 50 % de femmes de jeunes
femmes c'est des jeunes qui arrivent
avec un niveau de
formation
infra infra 5 donc c'est ce qu'on c'est
ce qu'on appelle le niveau CAP première
année le cap voilà passé non obtenu on a
des jeunes avec des niveaux 3e des
niveaux 4e des niveaux 5e qui sont
déscolarisés depuis longtemps pardon
alors qui sont déscolarisés depuis
longtemps pour certains on a des jeunes
qui peuvent être dcolarisés depuis au
moins 5 ans d'accord et pendant C ce
temps là donc ils ne sont plus à l'école
ils n'ont plus ses repères habituels
même de se lever pour venir à l'école ça
doit être très très dur lorsqu'ils
arrivent à l'école de la deuxième chance
tout à fait c'est c'est c'est c'est
toute une c'est toute une gymnastique
c'est toute une réorganisation
de la vie de ce jeune qui qui qui a
généralement des des des grosses
difficultés quand il arrive à l'école à
à honorer sa ponctualité à à venir
régulièrement tous les jours et cetera
donc bah tout ça c'est un travail de
fond que l'on fait avec l'équipe
pédagogique pour les amener à quelque
chose de régulier qui pour les préparer
aussi au monde du travail il a tout un
cadre à reprendre toute une éducation en
fait à reprendre la pualité la politesse
les échanges les uns avec les autres
voilà tout à fait il y a tout un cadre à
reprendre il y a il y a toute
une tous les codes à reconstruire aussi
bien les codes en entreprise mais les
codes relationnels euh et ça se fait
très progressivement dans le cadre de
leur parcours à l'école comment ça se
passe justement le le parcours d'un d'un
jeune qui vient vous voir qui a été qui
n'a pas été à l'école pendant plusieurs
années qui qui revient dans votre
structure comment vous l'accompagnez ça
dure combien temps comment ça se passe
alors euh comment ça se passe ces jeunes
sont pour la plupart orientés par par
l'émission locale on a un partenariat
assez solide avec l'mission locale et un
partenariat très actif avec la Mission
Locale de Saint-Quentin euh donc ils
sont reçus un entretien et donc
entretien au cours duquel on va retracer
un peu son parcours on va lui expliquer
le le le fonctionnement du parcours le
contenant du parcours ce qu'il attend
enfin l'objectif du parcours et euh donc
le le son dossier va passer en
commission pédagogique devant toute
l'équipe pédagogique pour statuer sur
son admission et quand le jeune intègre
l'école il intègre pour une période de
10 mois et demi
maximum avec une possibilité de partir à
un moment où il a finalisé son projet
professionnel alors c'est un parcours en
en c'est un parcours en deux temps enfin
en deux volets plutôt il y a un volet
remise à niveau enfin c'est le
développement des savoirs de base qui
qu'il a acquis déjà sur au au niveau de
sa scolarité
et le volet entreprise donc ils vont
alterner travail à l'école de remise à
niveau et stage en entreprise donc ils
vont arriver ils vont peut-être pour
certains é mettent déjà une idée de
projet pour d'autres ça va se construire
au fil du
parcours et donc le le le le jeûne va va
tout doucement partir d'une autoroute
qui est très large et et tracer une voie
qui va l'amener jusqu'à son objectif qui
est l'emploi la formation enfin ça sera
très variable en fonction du projet du
jeune les entreprises vous les avez
évooqué brièvement elle jouent le jeu
justement avec un contexte économique
difficile malgré tout elles prennent le
temps de les accompagner voir même de
leur proposer des emplois à l'issue de
la formation on a un partenariat très
fort avec les entreprises et les
entreprises jouent le jeu euh c'est très
important d'accompagner de tutorer ces
jeunes euh puisque comme je vous l'ai
dit tout à l'heure il y a il y a
beaucoup de choses à construire en
entreprise tous les codes en entreprise
et
euh le le le tutorin est d'autant plus
important que le jeune doit vraiment
être en immersion dans le métier dans
l'entreprise il doit apprendre à
travailler à s'intégrer à une équipe à
une nouvelle entreprise et ça à chaque
stage il va changer de stage
d'entreprise sur sur la série de de de
stages qu'il a effectué pour construire
son parcours
euh et donc l'entreprise est très
importante très importante elle joue le
jeu on a des partenariats très réguliers
euh et très récemment on a mis en place
un partenariat avec le club face aussi
euh pour mener des actions à la fois de
découverte de métiers euh euh permettre
aux jeunes de rencontrer des
professionnels pour les entraîner à des
à des entretiens pour euh voilà pour
échanger sur sur le contexte de
l'entreprise à l'issu de tout ça est-ce
qu'il trouvent un emploi à tous ces
jeunes alors 60 % des jeunes trouvent un
emploi une formation ou un contrat en
alternance donc soit contrat
d'apprentissage soit contrat de
professionnalisation on parle d'école de
la deuxième chance est-ce que c'est la
dernière chance pour eux est-ce que pour
ceux qui n'y arrivent pas il y a
d'autres choses est-ce que vous les
orientez vers autre chose ou est-ce que
Jain il n rien alors les les les les
jeunes qui qui n'y arrivent pas qui
abandonnent peut-être que pour certains
d'entre eux c'est trop tôt c'est trop
tôt c'est pas la dernière chance il faut
jamais il faut jamais raisonner en
dernière chance c'est peut-être trop tôt
voilà y a d'autres choses à vivre encore
en amont de notre parcours
euh le le le la difficulté la difficulté
enfin de de de beaucoup de ces jeunes
c'est vraiment de rentrer dans ce cadre
et de s'y plier alors certains y
rentrent d'autres pas
euh après on on essaie de on essaie
quand un jeune n'y arrive pas on essaie
vraiment de trouver des solutions
intermédiaire avec les partenaires
institutionnels qui travaillent dans
l'insertion pour donner voilà une voix à
ce jeune une voix différente mais
peut-être qu'il sera une voix
intermédiaire pour un retour éventuel à
l'école de la deuxième chance il y a des
jeunes pour qui vous vous êtes dit ça va
être très compliqué finalement tout
s'est bien passé tout c'est bien fini
oui bien sûr ça arrive souvent bien sûr
oui ça arrive des fois on voit arriver
des jeunes et puis on se dit où ça va
être compliqué
euh et puis finalement c'est c'est des
jeunes qui qui se révèl dans le
parcours on construit vraiment la
confiance en soi on construit l'école de
la deuxème chance et là vraiment pour
mettre le pied à l'étrier euh voilà sur
ce sur sur cet aspect de la confiance en
soi ils arrivent à l'école de la
deuxième chance ils ne savent rien faire
ils n'ont aucune ils n'ont aucune
qualité ils ne voilà ils ont ils ont une
image très négative d'eux-même et l'idée
c'est de rétablir cette cette image de
redonner la confiance en soi et après le
cheminement se fait de même quelle
perspective de développement on peut
imaginer pour le site de trappe ou même
dans les ivelines est-ce qu'il faudrait
élargir parce que vous nous disiez tout
à l'heure vous êtes contraint par la par
la place pour pouvoir les les accueillir
ces jeunes disons
que élargir le site pour l'instant ce
n'est pas envisageable dans la mesure où
effectivement les 100 parcours que l'on
peut être amené à réaliser sur l'école
au cours de l'année euh bah se
remplissent très progressivement on a
très peu de liste d'attente sur les
jeunes donc on constitue des groupes
très régulièrement tous les mois donc au
jour d'aujourd'hui le l'idée de de
d'agrandir l'école et d'augmenter les
effectifs voilà ça n'a pas trop de avoir
un meilleur maillage sur l'ensemble du
territoire du départ enfin sur
l'ensemble du département ce serait
est-ce que ce serait pertinent ou pas
est-ce que ces jeunes viennent qui
viennent d'ailleurs à l'école de trappe
viennent uniquement des alentours
viennent quelque alors les les écoles
les l'école de l'école de trappe
accueille des des jeunes de voilà sur
vraiment sur un territoire assez large
des ivelines on a des jeunes qui
viennent de Rambouillet de oud
de plaisir même si la
majorité des jeunes qui arrivent à
l'école de la 2uxeme chance sont issu de
la la communauté d'agglomération euh ça
représente un peu plus de 50 % 60 % même
euh voilà le maillage le maillage n'a
pas besoin puisque sur le territoire il
existe déjà du potentiel et et un nombre
de jeunes suffisant pour répondre
euh aux entrées l'école de la deème
chance pour conclure sur cette
présentation très détaillée de l'école
de la deuxème chance qui a un peu plus
de d'une dizaine d'années maintenant on
parlait tout à l'heure de de
l'implication des entreprises aussi les
entreprises jouent le jeu on reconnaît
aussi la nécessité dans le cadre d'un
d'un parcours un petit peu alternatif au
système éducatif classique la pérenité
de la structure c'est quelque chose
d'assuré aujourd'hui sur le plan
financier comment se passe le
financement alors le
financement c'est un financement qui qui
fait intervenir l'État qui fait
intervenir
la région le Fond Social Européen la
communauté
d'agglomération et également la taxe
d'apprentissage alors
après on œuvre pour que ces financements
soient pérennes et et puisse permettre
de continuer à faire vivre l'école
malgré tout il faut à chaque fois
relancer c'est ce que vouz nous dire
c'est c'est qu'à chaque fois il faut
effectivement relancer c'est tous les
ans c'est tous les ans les dossiers
qu'il faut constituer et cetera
donc bon voilà c'est après c'est c'est
comme toutes les toutes les associations
merci l'école de la deuxème chance qui
attend donc un peu plus de 15000 jeunes
à la fin de l'année sur l'ensemble du
territoire français avec des résultats
positifs vous l'avez souligné et
notamment sur le site de trap merci à
vous merci à vous la suite de cette de
ce journal c'est avec cette opération de
solidarité c'est une grande Zumba qui a
été organisée à traap afin de collecter
des fonds pour l'association imagine for
margaot qui aide la recherche sur les
traitements pour les enfants atteints de
cancer William l et Patrick Jacques de
DIM quand la musique guérit les mots cet
après-midi àrappe on danse pour le
plaisir mais surtout pour la bonne cause
organisé par l'association imagine for
Margot cette Zumba party géante a pour
objectif de récolter des fonds pour la
recherche européenne autour du cancer de
l'enfant l'association a été créée en
2012 suite au décès de margaot de qui
avait 14 ans qui est décédé d'une tumeur
cérébrale qui avait collecté toute seule
103000 € 335 et ses parents Olivier et
Patricia blanc ont créé l'association
pour aider la recherche à trouver des
nouveaux traitements sur les cancers
pédiatriques ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'il y a surtout 550 enfants par
an en France qui décède que le cancer
c'est la première cause de décès par
maladie une maladie contre laquelle
l'association lutte activement en
organisant de nombreux événements
l'action principale c'est la course
enfants sans cancer qui a lieu tous les
ans fin septembre au parc de saint-clou
en 2012 lors de la course enfants sans
cancer on a récolté 200000 € en 2013
400000 € et en 2014 665000 € aujourd'hui
on ne court pas mais on danse pour
l'occasion h professeurs bénévoles sont
venus prêter main forte à l'association
on va transpirer sourire chanter danser
se dépenser et et en même temps on fait
un bon geste pour l'association donc
dansse latine ça fait penser à
l'Amérique latine qui dit Amérique
latine soleil chaleur sourire guter donc
tout est là sourire c'était la seule
règle aujourd'hui pour les participants
venus apporter leur soutien à
l'association dans une ambiance festive
cadancée par les rythmes
tropicaux bonjour bonjour alors le sou
bah c'est une première pour moi c'est
bien c'est génial ça nous permet de
connaître et en plus ça aide les enfants
donc c'est une bonne cause lors de cette
journée 150 personnes ont répondu
présentes à l'appel et 1800 € ont été
récoltés prochain rendez-vous le 27
septembre à saintclou avec des
chaussures de
course rendre les lieux touristique
accessible aux personnes déficientes
visuelles grâce aux nouvelles
technologies c'est le défi relevé par
des lycéens de Versailles et par
l'association Valentin à8 un test
grandeur nature a été réalisé à la cour
des centeurs à Versailles un site qui
reçoit des visiteurs du monde entier
pour une découverte des traditions des
savoir-faire des matières premières
également qui composent l'univers des
parfums Mélanie
poire droit sur les et décter ver la
droite suivre ce RA pendant une
trentaine de P jusqu'à une jardinière en
béton visiter un lieu quand on est
déficient visuel ce n'est pas toujours
aisé ce jour-là plusieurs adhérents de
l'association Valentin testent divers
outils celui-ci est une application vous
êtes sur le belved glissez verticalement
sur votre écran pour pour avoir des
informations sur le jardin les grosses
difficultés c'est déjà
d'accéder extérieurement
parlant au lieu j'entends par exemple on
est ici à Versailles accéder au
démarrage d'une visite dans le château
c'est excessivement difficile parce
qu'on a cette grande place par exemple
la place d'arme moi je suis incapable de
me débrouiller seul sur la place d'ARM
c'est impossible VI un guidageud on
trouvait que la nouvelle technologie
permettait de le faire facilement
grâce à des balises qui utilisent la
technologie highbacon ou Bluetooth low
energy autre outil des plantes tactiles
ils ont été imaginés par 6 lycéens de
Notre-Dame du Grandchamp lors de la
atelier de terminale pendant 6 mois à
raison de 2 heur par semaine mais aussi
lorsqu'ils le souhaitaent ces jeunes ont
travaillé en collaboration avec
l'association ils ont aucun moyen de
voir du coup ça leur permet que leur
doigt d'avoir déjà une vision globale de
où est-ce qu'il faut aller quel chemin
il faut suivre s'il faut aller à droite
ou à gauche au nord au sud donc c'est
vraiment une vision globale ces plant
tactiles l'important c'était que en fait
tout a été fabriqué ici par les
étudiants on va dire qu'on les a un peu
encadré qu'on a un peu modifié un C
nombre de choses et c'est l'imprimerie
de AVH qui a imprimé ses plans donc ces
plans sont aujourd'hui tout à fait
valables tout à fait intéressants et je
peux vous assurer que quand un déficient
visuel parcourt ses plans pendant une
demi-heure ensuite il a tout à fait dans
son imaginaire le trajet qu'il va
pouvoir parcourir et il sait se
présenter ensuite mentalement totalement
le le trajet l'association Valentin hi
regroupe 400 personnes dont 200
déficients visuels aveugles ou malvoyant
et 180 bénévoles la découverte de la
cour des centeurs était une phase de
test l'association espère cependant
laavir se
généraliser on parle loisir à présent
des dinosaures à toiri une nouvelle
animation est en cours d'installation du
côté du parc zoologique elle va ouvrir
ses portes au public à partir du 30 mai
et sera proposée jusqu'à la fin de l'été
une quinzaine d'espèces de dinosaures à
découvrir investissement de plus de
300000 € qui devrait être malgré tout
vite rentabilisé alors qu'un nouveau
volet de Jurassic Park est attendu au
cinéma mi-juin Floran parfait et le
[Musique]
dimoine attention ils arrivent un
tyrannosaur Rex un tricératops ou encore
un parasoloropus ils sont 16 et ce sont
les nouveaux pensionnaires du zoo de
toiri ces animaux préhistoriques
mesurent jusqu'à 10 m de haut et pèse
plus d'une tonne ils viennent tout droit
du Texas un mois a été nécessaire pour
les transporter mais pas de crainte
s'ils bougent et grogne ils ne sont pas
affamés car ce sont des animatroniques
prêté par une société
américaine nous faisons des
animatronique c'est notre activité
principale ensuite la société met en
place des partenariats et nous les
louons entre 3 et 6 mois en
général ce sont tous des animatroniques
ils bougent tous ils utilisent tous de
l'air compressé et aussi un peu
d'électricité pour contrôler le
programme cela fonctionne sur le
principe du pneumatique c'est ce qui
produit le mouvement ces gigantesques
animaux robotisés vont pouvoir bouger
d'ici une semaine le temps utile pour
l'installation des mécanismes les
dinosaures vont être intégrés avec des
plantes et un aménagement spécifique un
peu partout dans le zoo un
investissement conséquent environ 300000
€ un événement estival qui devrait
attirer de nouveaux visiteurs et reste
en adéquation avec la philosophie Toir
on a pensé au dinosaures c'est pas
complètement anodin les dinosaures c'est
aussi une espèce qui a disparu à un
moment donné et d'ailleurs on va voir
tout un circuit pédagogique et avec des
animateurs qui vont expliquer que un
parc zoologique c'est fait c'est fait
pour préserver les espèces et que la
disparition des animaux c'est aussi
concret les dinosaures et puis c'est
Ludi on accueille des familles et on
avait envie aussi de s'amuser avec notre
public les dinosaures seront visibles
aux EAU DE Toir à partir du 30 mai et
jusqu'au 30 août prochain un petit goût
de Jurassic Park avec les frissons en
moins enfin pas si
sûr et des dinosaures à toiri est-ce que
l'idée vous surprend irirez-vous rendre
visite à ces espèces disparues c'est
notre question du jour bah
oui pourquoi bah je sais pas parce que
les dinosaures ils sont morts ah non non
non non c'est bien justement puisquils
existent plus ce serait leur
représentant du coup voilà ça
permettrait à à tous ceux qui ne
connaissent pas ces espèce là de de les
connaître enfin d'en connaître au moins
la structure oui ça me surprend parce
que ça existe plus les dinosaures oui ça
me surprend oui pourquoi parce que ils
sont éteints les dinosaures il me semble
c'est une bonne idée je pense j'iraai
voir ça peut faire connaître enfin
comment qu les espèces qui existaient
avant qu' nous on existe donc c'est une
bonne idée pour la culture générale des
jeunes et même des des grands pourquoi
pas après faudrait qu'il soit vivant
serait plus marrant du 30 mai jusqu'à la
fin du mois de d'août pour découvrir ces
dinosaures le comité de quartier
jean-massetis attrape au rythme du
carnaval de printemps retour sur ce
moment festif avec William l sur des
images de Patrick Jacques de
dixmud à l'arrivée des beaujours le
quartier jeanmassé de trappe s'anime
tout au long de l'année le comité de
quartier organise des événements pour
rassembler les riverins ce weekend
c'était le carnaval l'tif c'est de de
pouvoir être ensemble de se connaître un
peu plus parce que dans une grande cité
comme ça on se voit c'est vrai on se dit
bonjour mais on n pas le temps vraiment
de parler donc c'est un rassemblement
entre nous tous un rassemblement qui
tise des liens car les voisins c'est un
peu comme une deuxième famille moi les
voisins c'est très
important tous ces gens-là on se connaî
je je les appelais comme mes voisins de
mon village là où je suis né
contrairement à ce que beaucoup de gens
pensent il y a quand même pas mal
d'activité à trpe tout le monde se
plaint tout le temps que jamais rien se
passe et puis B quand il y a quelque
chose c'est quand même intéressant de de
pouvoir venir les enfants son toujours
contents il voient des des enfants de
leur âge leur école ou pas ou ou du
sport donc c'est toujours c'est toujours
très très bien en tout cas je veux dire
c'est même très très bien organisé hein
c'est monsieurs asseyez-vous on va vous
VI prendre la commande on se c vraiment
au restaurant c'est très très bien
organisé c'est au top là je dirais
aujourd'hui pour cette 5e édition une
cinquantaine de personnes est venu faire
connaissance autour d'une crêpe le
prochain rendez-vous du comité de
quartier sera en join et en
musique et pour terminer ce journal
votre pronostic sur le match Barça PSG
de ce soir dans quelques heures le
pariss- sa-germain qui va tenter
l'exploit sur la pelouse espagnole
mission presque impossible vos avis je
dirais qu'au niveau des des pronostics
et statistiques et probabilité
ouais je dis qu'ils ont aucune chance de
gagner j'espère qu'ils vont se qualifier
mais je pense pas parce que ça va quand
même être compliqué je crois qu'il faut
qu'il marque 3-0 pour que il gagne donc
peut-être hein on sait jamais avec le
foot ça peut ça peut tout tout peut
arriver mais mais bon on verra he
peut-être 21 pour le parisint-germain je
sais pas c'est impossible soit 2A soit
3A pour Barça pour le Barça éidemment
j'espère qu'il gagne 1 2
30 verdicte donc demain pour ce 3-0
prochain journal demain mardi juste
mercredi pardon au mêmes horaires tout
de suite sur TVfil 78 le 78 société
présenté préparé par noadine Agne débat
de la semaine autour des signes
religieux à l'université très bonne
soirée
[Musique]